- [Voiceover] Now we're gonna talk about
the idea of impedance.
This is a really important
idea in electronics
and it's something that comes
from the study of AC analysis.
And AC analysis is where we
limit ourselves to inputs
to our circuits that look like
sinusoids, cosines or sines.
And of all the signals
that we could possibly have
in the entire universe,
we're gonna limit ourselves
just for the moment, to sine waves.
And there's some great simplifications
that emerge from this.
So in this video, we're gonna look at,
we're gonna develop,
basically the i-v equations
for our three favorite passive components,
resistor, inductor, and capacitor.
And we're gonna look at those
when the input is a sinusoid.
So that means that i or v,
the voltage or the current
is in the shape of a sinusoid.
And we're gonna see what that
means for the i-v equations
for our favorite devices.
So as we look at i-v equations
with sinusoid inputs,
we're actually gonna break down sinusoids
into complex exponentials.
And when we studied
sinusoids, we found out
that we could disassemble sinusoids
into complex exponentials
using Euler's equation.
So, for example, if we have a cosine wave,
if we have a cosine as a function of time,
omega t, we can express that
in terms of complex
exponentials like this:
1/2 e to the plus j omega t
plus e to the minus j omega t.
Like that.
And what I'm gonna do
now is I'm gonna say,
let's look at what happens
when we use this as an input signal.
This is not a real input signal,
it's an imaginary, rotating vector.
But if I have two of these,
I can reassemble them into a cosine wave.
And we like to use these exponentials,
because they go through
the differential equations
of a circuit really easily.
These are the inputs
that we know how to solve
when we do differential equations.
So what I'm gonna do is
develop the i-v equations
for the resistor, inductor, and capacitor
in terms of this kind of an input,
when the voltage or the
current looks like this,
what do those equations look like?
So we're gonna start with,
we'll start with the resistor.
Here's a resistor.
And we know from that
that just Ohm's law is
v equals i times R.
And just for the moment I'm
gonna assume that the current,
let's assume that i equals
e to the plus j omega t.
So if this is i, what
is v for our resistor?
Well, we just plug i in here
and we get v equals
R times e to the plus j omega t.
All right.
Now I'm gonna do something that looks like
it's a little too simple,
but it's gonna get interesting soon.
I wanna look at the ratio
of voltage to current.
In this situation where we're driving
with this complex exponential.
So voltage turned out to be
R e to the plus j omega t
and that's the voltage
I get if I put current
though the resistor of
e to the plus j omega t.
And what does that equal to?
Well, these two are the
same so they cancel,
and I get the ratio of voltage to current
is R for a resistor.
So for our resistor we just proved
that v over i equals R.
So this isn't news, we
didn't make a discovery here,
this is just Ohm's law.
And for a resistor, the
voltage over the current
is always equal to the resistance.
All right.
This is gonna get more
interesting now as we go do
inductors and capcitors.
So let's do an inductor.
It has a value of L henries.
And for an inductor we know
that voltage equals L di dt.
All right, and let's do
the same thing again.
Let i equal e to the plus j omega t.
So it's a complex exponential current
that we're forcing through our inductor.
And let's go ahead and work out what v is.
So v equals L times d dt
of this value here, e
to the plus j omega t.
Or v equals, now we take the derivative
and the j omega term
comes down to multiply L,
so we get j omega L times what?
Times the same thing, e
to the plus j omega t,
this is the beautiful
thing about exponentials,
they give us back themselves.
All right, now let's do this.
Let's take, once more,
what's the ratio of voltage to current?
And that equals, here's the voltage,
j omega L times e to the plus j omega t,
and let's divide that by i
which is i is right here,
i is e to the plus j omega t.
So, those cancel.
And we get
v over i equals j omega L.
So now we have an equation
for v over i for an inductor.
And this is interesting,
this time we have the inductance value
which we expected, and
there's also this omega,
j omega term that comes in.
So this tells us this is
frequency, omega is frequency.
So this tells us that the
ratio of v to i for an inductor
is dependent on frequency.
Now we'll do the same
thing for a capacitor.
So here's a capacitor.
And there's it's
capacitance value in farads.
And for the capacitor, we know
that i equals C times dv dt.
And this time let's let v of t,
let's let v equal e to the plus j omega t.
So this time we're gonna force
a voltage across our capacitor
that is this imaginary,
this complex exponential.
And that gives us, let's
plug that into here,
i equals C times d dt
of e to the plus j omega t.
Now let's take that derivative
i equals, same thing happens,
j omega comes down to
multiply out in front with C,
and we get the same thing over here.
So we get j omega C times
e to the plus j omega t.
And now we'll ask the same question again
that we did before, which is
what is v over i for capacitor?
And we can fill this in,
v is sitting right here,
v is e to the j omega t,
e to the plus j omega t
and the current is, we
worked that out down here,
that's j omega C
times e to the plus j omega t.
And once again, we get this
nice cancellation here,
this cancels with this,
and for capacitor we get
v over i equals
one over j omega C.
And we put a box around that one too.
So this says that the
ratio of voltage to current
in a capacitor, it depends on
the value of the capacitor,
of course, and it also
depends on frequency.
So just like over with the inductor,
we have a frequency term in here.
So now we're gonna give this
ratio of voltage to current
in all three cases, we're
gonna give a special name
and that name is impedance.
And the symbol we often
use for impedance is a Z.
So this word impedance
is the general notion
of the ratio of voltage to current.
And we can do that for all
three of our passive components.
For a resistor, the impedance
is its resistance, R.
So the word impedance is
like the word resistance,
except it's a more general concept.
It's the general concept of
voltage divided by current.
For a resistor, the
impedance is the resistance.
For an inductor, the impedance,
v over i is j omega L.
And down here for
capacitor, the impedance is
one over j omega C, for capacitance.
So this is where the idea of
impedance, this word impedance,
this is where it comes from.
And the idea includes both
the values of the components
and the effect that frequency has
on the voltage to current ratio.
So both of those things
are combined into one idea.
So just a quick summary of impedance,
if we say the impedance of
a resistor, that equals R.
The impedance of an
inductor equals j omega L.
And the impedance of a capacitor
equals one over j omega C.
And as a reminder of
the assumptions we made,
we said that we're only gonna
consider sinusoidal inputs.
And what we did is we
broke up our sinusoid,
our cosine wave, into these,
we looked at how these
rotating vectors passed
through our components in the
form of voltages and currents.
So there's no new physics here.
What happened is we took these j omegas
that came out of the exponentials
when we took the derivatives,
we associated those with
the component itself,
we did that here and we did that here,
and you can see it here.
So we sort of done,
it's somewhat of a notational trick.
We associate this frequency dependence,
not with the inputs and
the voltages and currents,
but with the components themselves.
And this is something we call,
this is referred to as transforming.
We transformed our components.
That's the phrase that's used there.
But from this comes the idea of impedance
and in the general sense of
the voltage to current ratio.